91 avions de chasse 12 navires de guerre
chinois qui encercle totalement l'île de
Taïwan
même des tirs en cette troisième et
dernière journée de l'opération
militaire menée par l'armée chinoise en
guise d'avertissement
un avertissement contre les activités
provocatrices de Taïwan a expliqué le
porte-parole de Pékin alors que le
rapprochement entre les États-Unis et
l'État insulaire dérange la Chine
c'est cette rencontre mercredi dernier
entre le président de la Chambre des
Représentants Kevin McCarty et la
présidente de Taïwan karavée les
tensions
le porte-parole du ministère taïwanais
de la défense pour justifier le
harcèlement et les actions qui
compromettent gravement la sécurité dans
la région
mais pour les résidences c'est presque
devenu une habitude
lanc swag wendan nous sommes nerveux
mais pas inquiet l'exercice militaire ne
fait même pas les manchettes là-bas
beaucoup estiment que c'est du bluff et
qu'ils seront de toute façon défendus
par les États-Unis donc paradoxalement
les
Occidentaux sont parfois plus inquiets
que les que les Taïwanais eux-mêmes les
États-Unis ont déjà promis de fournir
des armes à Taïwan tandis que la Russie
a fait chou vertement son soutien Pékin
dont l'objectif demeure la reprise du
contrôle de Taïwan nous avons
aujourd'hui à oeuvre pour éviter tout
escalade mais c'est la position
d'Emmanuel Macron qui surprend à son
retour de sa visite d'État en Chine
après avoir évité le sujet de Taïwan le
président français affirmé que l'Europe
ne devait pas être suivie des États-Unis
pour éviter d'être entraîné dans un
éventuel affrontement avec la Chine une
déclaration qui bouscule les relations
diplomatiques alors que les alliances ne
font qu'accentuer et des frictions déjà
vive ici Jacques Audric Charbonneau
Radio-Canada MONT